with massive cancellation some are
looking to rental cars to try to get to
their destinations but rental car
companies are just struggling to keep up
with demand Madison Kimbrough joins us
now live at Harry Reid International
with more
many Travelers deciding to drive home
this holiday season for the lack of
flights available as their flights are
either going to be canceled or delayed
yet again but with the low inventory and
high cost of rental cars many believe
it's created a whole new realm of
problems take a listen
the cost I would say safely doubled if
not tripled there are many people that
can't do that
and so they just skipped getting
together with their family because it's
just out of the question it's so
expensive Sandra Curry who was visiting
with her granddaughter acknowledges how
insane rental car prices are right now
due to an influx of Travelers booking
rides just to get back home
with thousands of flights across the
country canceled rental car companies
are booking up fast and very few cars
are available at this point it'd be
really nice if they could find a better
way to get people in and out and where
they need to go a little quicker and
more efficiently Billy Spencer is
traveling with his daughter from Austin
Texas and says through all of this he
feels taken advantage of I'm paying
eighteen hundred dollars for one day so
that means that the rental cars
companies are gouging
you know folks that are stuck
he plans to drive all the way to Seattle
to get their lost luggage and then take
a flight back to Texas not the holiday
they were expecting going back to the
airport's not an option there are no
flights for the next several days so
that company was literally the only
option and I had to book it online
and while we were at the Rent-A-Car
facility Avis and six Rent-A-Car were
the only two companies taking
reservations now as you can see we're
here at baggage claim where there are
plenty of people here trying to figure
out their next move reporting live
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now